einer der größten wissenschaftlichen
Durchbrüche aller Zeiten das sagt sogar
das renommierte Fachmagazin science mit
der Hilfe der künstlichen Intelligenz
das sieht mein ki-systems Alpha fold
konnten deutsche forschende jetzt eines
der größten molekülkomplexe die es in
menschlichen Zellen gibt entschlüsseln
bisher war das absolut unmöglich geklärt
werden könnten damit möglicherweise auch
zahlreiche ungelöste Rätsel über
Aidsviren und corona-erreger Krieg zum
science and future hier gibt's dreimal
pro Woche spannendes heinz-videos
abonniert den Kanal und aktiviert die
Glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen laut dem
renommierten Fachmagazin science ist das
der wissenschaftliche Durchbruch des
Jahres es geht um die Proteinfaltung die
mit der Hilfe der künstlichen
Intelligenz alphafault endlich
aufgeklärt werden kann damit ist eines
der großen Rätsel der Wissenschaft
einfach keins mehr BÄM die Rede ist vom
KI-System der britischen Google oder
respektive Alphabet Tochter deep meint
jetzt konnte auch ein deutsches
Forschungsteam mit der Hilfe dieser KI
einen wichtigen Meilenstein erreichen es
geht um sehr große
molekülkomplexe in menschlichen Zellen
die sogenannten Kernporen werden
aufgrund ihrer Funktion manchmal auch
als Verkehrsknotenpunkte der Zellen
genannt endlich konnte jetzt ihre
Gestalt bestimmt werden einem deutschen
Forschungsteam um den Biologen Jan
Kosinski ist jetzt dieser Durchbruch
gelungen der im letzten Jahr noch undenk
mit konventionellen Forschungsmethoden
wie der Elektronenmikroskopie hätte das
möglicherweise 10 Jahre oder noch länger
gedauert wenn es denn überhaupt geklappt
hätte versteht schon jetzt darauf werden
viele weitere Durchbrüche folgen denn
die KI und speziell alphafold treibt die
bio-wissenschaften enorm an wenn
Proteine schneller erforscht werden
können könnten der Folge auch schneller
neue Wirkstoffe gefunden werden doch wie
genau funktioniert die KI alpha-fold und
was verrät uns die nun aufgeklärte
Gestalt der Kernporen über ihre
Funktionsweise die spannenden Antworten
auf diese Fragen und noch viel mehr
gibt's jetzt hier von mir die 3D
Struktur von Protein daran beißen sich
Fachleute aus der gesamten Welt seit
einem halben Jahrhundert die Zähne aus
dabei handelt es sich bei Proteinen um
die Bausteine des Lebens und sie sind
wichtig für alle möglichen Funktionen
unseres Körpers ohne sie gäbe es kein
Leben so einfach ist es ein Tief
Verständnis dazu könnte zahlreiche Leben
retten beispielsweise auch jetzt im
weltweiten Kampf gegen das Coronavirus
seit Beginn der Pandemie sind Proteine
in aller Munde als Stachel des
Coronavirus spike-proteine oder als
Protein im Stoff novawachs Proteine
gehören aber auch ansonsten in unseren
Alltag sie steuern den Stoffwechsel sind
wichtiger Bestandteil unserer Nahrung
oder gehen als Bestandteil von
Waschmitteln hartnäckige Flecken in der
Kleidung an entscheidend für ihre
Funktion die dreidimensionale
Strukturproteine selbst bestehen aus
einer Kette von Aminosäuren und deren
Abfolge ergibt sich aus der genetischen
Bauanleitung die Faltung der
aminosäurenketten dagegen ist alles
andere als vorhersagbar dahinter stecken
tatsächlich zahlreiche Faktoren dazu der
Max-Planck-Wissenschaftler Jürgen Cox
obwohl diese Strukturen eindeutig durch
die Gesetze der Physik vorgegeben sind
ist deren Berechnung ausgehend von den
grundlegenden Formeln der
Quantenmechanik als aussichtslos
anzusehen der dazu benötigt Aufwand wäre
gigantisch um die Funktionen von Protein
zu verstehen müssen Fachleute ihre
Gestalt kennen sie sind ja wie ein
Multitool um zu verstehen was ein
Multitool kann muss man einfach wissen
was da alles drin ist dafür kann die
Sequenz der Proteine analysiert werden
woraus ein Computer dann in der Theorie
die Form berechnen könnte doch
Fehlanzeige denn die chemischen und
physikalischen Wechselspiele zwischen
den einzelnen Aminosäuren sind so
komplex dass hierbei sogar Supercomputer
kapituliert und so kommt es dass trotz
intensiver Forschung bislang nur von
rund 1 % der Proteine die 3D Struktur
bekannt ist eine Art heiliger Gral der
Zellbiologie also die alles
entscheidende Frage die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
weltweit bereits seit rund 50 Jahren
umtreibt lässt sich anhand der
aminosäurenabfolge eine Vorhersage
darüber treffen wie die finale Gestalt
eines Proteins aussehen wird der
wissenschaftliche Durchbruch des Jahres
2021 dreht sich genau um dieses die Rede
ist von Deep meint dem
ki-forschungszentrum von Google die oder
Alphabet die Fachleute hatten mit Alpha
fold ein lernfähiges KI-System
geschaffen das von den
Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftlern darauf trainiert wurde
Gesetzmäßigkeiten in der Proteinfaltung
zu erkennen es handelt sich um ein
neuronales Netzwerk und trainiert wurde
ist mit der Hilfe von
170.000 bekannten Proteinstrukturen dem
KI-System gelang es dann bei einem
Wettbewerb die Struktur von 70 der
insgesamt 100 zu lösen im Protein
Abfolgen vorherzusagen und zwar mit
hoher Präzision das war vorher noch mit
Abstand einfach unmöglich bei dem
sogenannten global distance Test GDT
wird aufgeschlüsselt wie nah die
prognostizierten Positionen der
Proteinkomponenten ihrer tatsächlichen
Position sind alphafold Schnitt
überraschend gut ab insgesamt 100 Punkte
waren zu erreichen durchschnittlich
erreichte Alphaville 92,
wie die die Punkte und selbst bei den
Strukturen die in der Fachwelt als
kompliziert zu knacken eingestuft wurden
erreichte das KI-System 85 GDT Punkte
die künstliche Intelligenz von Deep
meint ist also ganz weit vorne und das
mit extrem weitem Abstand denn solch
eine Präzision wird normalerweise nur
bei experimentellen Analysen erreicht
die teilweise jahrelange Arbeit in
Anspruch nehmen schnell stand also fest
dass alpha-fold die Biologie
revolutionieren könnte ein Beweis dafür
gibt es jetzt am Hamburger
Teilchenbeschleuniger Daisy auch hier
setzt man im Fachbereich
Strukturbiologie des europäischen
molekularbiologischen Labors auf die
ki-alpha folgt inhaltlich haben die
Fachleute hier vor allem die sogenannten
Kernporen im Visier es handelt sich um
riesige molekülkomplexe die aus rund
1000 einzelnen protein-molekülen 30
verschiedene Typen bestehen sie regeln
was in den Zellkern nein und wieder
herauskommt an streng bewachtes
Einfallstor in die Zelle alles muss
durch diese molekularen
Verkehrsknotenpunkte hindurch eine super
wichtige Funktion also doch viele Fragen
in diesem Bereich sind noch umgekehrt
wie schaffen es beispielsweise
Grippeerreger oder Aids Viren in das
Innere der Zellen und warum sind
corona-erreger in der Lage den
Stoffwechsel der Zellen zu drosseln um
endlich Antworten auf all diese
spannenden Fragen zu bekommen müsste die
genaue Wirkungsweise dieser
interzellulären Schleusen im Detail
verstanden werden eine Mammutaufgabe und
bis dann ist es noch nie gelungen einen
solch großen Proteinkomplex annähernd
auch nur aufzuklären denn das ist
tatsächlich die Potenzierung der
bisherigen Aufgabe jetzt geht es nicht
mehr um ein einzelnes Protein sondern um
das hochkomplexe Zusammenspiel von 30
doch dieser gigantische gordische Knoten
wurde jetzt tatsächlich ja nicht
zerschlagen sondern entwirrt und das ist
der absolute Wahn dazu sagt der Biologe
Jan Kosinski vor wenigen Monaten hätte
ich das noch für undenkbar gehalten doch
als im vergangenen Sommer einen
umfangreicher proteinkatalog von Dieb
meint veröffentlicht wurde gab es für
seine Forschungsgruppe einen großen
Aufschwung denn darin zu finden sind
alle Proteinstrukturen die die
Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
für ihre Arbeit benötigen somit war also
die konkrete Gestalt aller Bausteine des
kernporenkomplexes bekannt BAM doch
damit ging das große Puzzle ja erst los
denn tausend einzelne Proteinmoleküle
lassen sich auf unzählig viele
verschiedene Arten und Weisen zu einem
großen Ganzen zusammensetzen wie also
setzt sich genau dieser große
molekülkomplex zusammen doch ein großer
Vorteil von Alpha fold die KI lernt dazu
und bereits in vergangenen Herbst konnte
weiterhin die Gestalt von knapp
4500 Proteinkomplexen vorgestellt werden
auch das Puzzle um die Kernporen so
jetzt gelöst werden nach und nach also
konnte die künstliche Intelligenz die
Gestalt entschlüsseln und den
Forschenden diese auf ihren Bildschirmen
Anzeigen zu sehen sind drei Ringe die
übereinander gestapelt sind das erste
Mal sieht die Menschheit jetzt also ganz
klar und deutlich auf eine solche
komplexe Proteinstruktur und versteht
sie dass es absolut mein blowing sie
erinnern an Bullaugen die den Blick
durch die Membran des Zellkerns
ermöglichen eine Art Gestänge Zeit nach
innen das möglicherweise Moleküle zum
Export nach außen stolz Filamente ragen
nach außen in das Zellplasma bewegliche
Protein Kordeln bilden eine Art Vorhang
der den Durchgang darstellt diese ganzen
Erkenntnisse sind entscheidend um
medizinische Anwendung zu entwickeln
Medikamente zu verbessern denn bislang
sind bereits mehrere Erbkrankheiten
bekannt die wohl auf defekte der
Kernporen zurückzuführen sind aber auch
Viren nutzen diese verkehrsk Punkte um
mir Unwesen zur Zeit so auch die
Coronaviren die die Kernporen angreifen
dazu Jan Kosinski eines der Virus
Proteine dockt an der Öffnung an und
behindert den Verkehr die Zellen sind so
möglicherweise nicht mehr in der Lage
die viralen Angreifer abzuwehren ist
Alpha fault auch also ein Wundermittel
versteht dass das gesamte Forschungsfeld
durch den Einsatz von KI verwandelt wird
doch gibt es einige Schwachpunkte
weswegen die experimentellen Methoden
zumindest in der nahen Zukunft sicher
nicht ganz ersetzt werden können denn
alpha-fold ignoriert die Zeit und somit
den Fakt das Proteine dynamisch sind und
sich verformt beispielsweise dann wenn
Sie sich mit anderen Proteinen zu einem
größeren Komplex verbinden oder aber ein
Wirkstoff andockt ein weiterer
Kritikpunkt die Präzision mit der die KI
die Position einzelner Atome innerhalb
eines Proteins angibt ist vor allem an
den bindetaschen manchmal noch nicht
ausreichend doch mehr Trainingsdaten von
tell untersuchten bindetaschen könnten
hier Abhilfe schaffen und die KI
zuverlässiger werden lassen fest steht
jedenfalls schon jetzt alpha-fold gehört
laut science zu den wissenschaftlichen
Durchbrüchen des letzten Jahres 2021
dazu sagt der Science Chefredakteur
holten stop der Durchbruch bei der
Proteinfaltung ist einer der größten
aller Zeiten sowohl in Bezug auf die
wissenschaftliche Leistung als auch mit
Blick auf dadurch mögliche künftige
Forschung nach Ansicht der Fachleute
vergleichbar mit der genschere Chris Bar
und die hat ja nicht weniger als die
Gentechnik revolutioniert Durchbruch bei
KI deep meint hier revolutioniert die
Medizin schon vor drei Jahren habe ich
hier bei Klick zum detailliert erklärt
wie Alpha fold die Medizin ja umkrempelt
wenn ihr mehr davon erfahren wollt hier
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran